you might know like we'll be jordan from
any number of scene-stealing roles like
Steve Montgomery and Chronicle but
chances are you've never seen him as fit
as he is in his most recent movies the
actor put on some serious muscle to
convincingly play the son of a legendary
boxer and Creed and a villainous
revolutionary in black panther so how
did he get so swole here's a look at how
Michael B Jordan got ripped for
Hollywood Creed well he's always been
fit Jordan had to get seriously buff
when he took the title role of Adonis
Creed in the 2015 boxing flick Creed
playing the son of legendary boxer
Apollo Creed from the Rocky films
required Jordan to take things to the
next level which he did with the help of
professional trainer Corey Calle in
order to properly portray a boxer Jordan
had to train like a boxer that meant 45
to 60 minutes daily of cardio along with
tons of ab workouts like crunches
mountain climbers leg raises reverse
crunches and traditional sit-ups to
build up his core and burn fat as for
building muscle Calle had Jordan focus
on super sets exercising we're lifting
or curling dumbbells are interspersed
with push-ups or another workout and
after that three full hours of boxing
training
this ain't your normal workout this is a
rocky Stadtwerke all told Jordan packed
on 24 pounds of muscle over a year of
training
according to Calle it was hard going at
first when we first started he could
barely bench 20 pounds his legs were
flailing everywhere he had nothing he
used to hate all this Jordan agreed
saying I felt muscles I didn't even know
I had it worked though so Jordan brought
kaya along with him to help add another
20 pounds of muscle in order to play the
super villain Eric kill longer in black
panther but that's not all Jordan did in
order to get ready for his big Marvel
moment nutrition nutrition nutrition as
any fitness buff worth his salt will
tell you exercise is only half the
battle when it comes to getting your
body into peak shape for Jordan to get
into literal fighting condition he had
to cut his food intake almost entirely
to lean proteins carbs green veggies and
protein shakes according to Jordan I
strip down my diet completely I worked
out two to three times a day six days a
week and if you do that consistently for
about ten months your body will change
don't worry though because on the
seventh day
Jordan rested as ka allowed him to cheat
on his
once a week with french toast in the
morning Philly cheesesteaks in the
afternoon and pizza yum self-motivation
is key Jordan told vice sports he
credits growing up in Newark with a
supportive family as the inspiration for
his work ethic and aspirations one day I
used to tell me all the time I you gotta
be serious about something that
motivation has been absolutely key to
Jordan's physical transformation pushing
it into heavier weights and longer runs
no matter how painful the workout Jordan
can persevere
thanks to that motivation it's all
myself at a young age that was gonna
like sacrifice I used to run myself into
the ground so like pure exhaustion just
because then I'll feel like I deserve it
also providing motivation the results
Jordan told Men's Fitness you know at
first you're hurting but when you start
bench-pressing
225 pounds ten times and it ain't
nothing and then you start giving hugs
to girls and they're like feeling you up
a little so I learned to love it when I
started seeing results method training
being in fighting shape from Creed
definitely helped Jordan transition to
the training for Black Panther where he
used a new technique called method
training the technique adapts Jordans
workouts to match what his character
would do to stay in shape helping
alleviate the dreaded workout boredom
those workouts included a comprehensive
weapons training program in addition to
learning various forms of martial arts
for Jordan it was a real departure from
the boxing focused training of creed
Jordan told collider
this one is more martial arts using a
lot of your legs so I'm picking up
different fighting styles also a lot of
guns to the weapons training is a
totally different muscle no rest for the
wicked leafit while any normal person
might want to take a break from nonstop
workout routines and just eat some pizza
and drink some beer
Jordan is jumping right back into
training for Creed to the story we'll
follow Adonis Creed fighting the son of
Ivan Drago a man who killed Apollo Creed
in the ring in rocky for professional
boxer Florian Montano will be playing
the son of Ivan Drago and at six foot
four and 245 pounds
Jordan has his work cut out for him but
if there's one thing as training is
proven so far it's that Jordan isn't
afraid of a little hard work thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
you
[Music]